let's just go one step further so you
know like I recently watched a high
fidelity then not the old one but the
new one with zoe kravitz and stuff and
the whole premise of that is going
through what if she call like five like
like all-time desert heartbreak as to
which he calls it so who are your five
all-time or at least names three
all-time most painful heartbreak list
but they all happened you know in my
early 20s and late teens it never
happened
[Music]
okay I want to know I'm sick alright so
um the first one was there was this girl
I went to school high school and there
was a girl I went to high school with
but her younger sister when I graduated
right she was only a year or two younger
than me I used to hang out with her her
name was Ashley brown right and I
remember watching like movies a movie
together her house in under a blanket
and just in my head like you know make a
move make a move but but I would never
do it I was just like so stiff and just
like I was like you know the little
Korean best friend right and then after
that was this girl named Rebecca Dreskin
I had a crush on her as well and then we
just became friends and then but the
third was alveus I've talked about her
Anna be elderness mm-hmm when I was but
then there was one that happened I can't
say her name but this is one that
happened before you babe where I I liked
her and then I knew that she had hooked
up with Jules and my kurz that are still
kind of open my kurz right and then when
I went went to make a move or whatever
she said um I just want to be friends
I'm not attracted to you
but then in my mind I knew that she had
dated two guys that weren't even [ __ ]
funny
they were underneath me and I want to
say their name so [ __ ] back alright
well I'll say one of the guys names
right I know Michael anoche so Michael
anoche had hooked up was there right and
I want and and when she said that I was
just like I know put the [ __ ] mask on
and I went in my head I was just like
I'm a [ __ ] loser oh my god the Oh
like if I say the other night I don't
want to put the [ __ ] throw on them it
makes you feel good I say the other name
right
it's worse than Michael anoche I want to
know tell me later Dave Chappelle no you
know it's Michael got even underneath
Michael anoche right so uh I got so many
revelations I I think I've talked about
my my top three or at least top yeah top
five heartbreak lists on this podcast no
yeah it's always in you but you're right
it's always in your early 20s or in your
teens nothing compares to that [ __ ]
pain of being a nun short teenager and
wanting something so badly and not
knowing how to navigate that whole
process of feelings toward somebody know
you also think that it's it's the most
important thing in one's life it
consumes your entire body when you
realize that oh no I am career and there
are other things like health and you
know I wasn't raised yeah and there's so
many other things later in life that
like become as important or more
important and then all of a sudden you
realize that you know it's it's just not
real those feelings it's more derived
from your mind and fantasy and you
you're very much still in a bubble like
you haven't been out there in the world
yet for me it was see the names baby
yeah I will and in fact you know what
I'm gonna try to - I know which one it
why I'm down for a patreon maybe I can
have some of my feelings resolved a
Filipino guy from the Philippines that
guy who froggy know the guy that right
now is it you know I know I love
Jonathan Vilia Gras
yeah his nickname was froggy he was
really fast but that wasn't him he
wasn't my bonum another guy no you're
not talking about talking about the guy
right that's a big business guy now me
right he's in the business right now and
then earlier on you had a crush on him
no baby we dated baby was his name do we
have to yeah yeah what's his name am i
bleeding yes
no don't believe it what's his name his
name was Dino Dino Dino mouth baby the
heartbreak for me my first heartbreak
heartbreak or first unrequited love was
Puerto Rican Gary Gary Gonzales hey
what's worse Gary but he was he was so
cool amongst the other kids he was just
always that and but what he did was I I
made out with him in the back of a
chemistry classroom and I did give him
head and then it ruined my reputation
for for the rest of like my entire high
school hated high school by the way
and then everyone started calling me a
face queen Gary she's very good at it
he'll probably agree but I mean and then
he broke my heart
Julie I cover your ears Rudy get out of
the room well she just kind of took her
mouth and just at the head of my penis
and just a little suck she would like
that a little stuck on my head of my
penis I don't do that yeah and it felt
so wonderous that didn't happen no
straight from Glendale Gaby where she
[Laughter]